- I love your, I love your red.
(crowd applauds)
- oh, I love red.
I'm very, I was going eighties
with my liner and everything.
Congrats, you just had a son, right?
The- since the last time I saw you.
- Yeah.
So that's, is that six girls and one boy?
- I got six girls and one boy.
- You got there.
- Yeah.
- You got there, you got that boy.
- Oh man, ain't that somthin'
- Yeah.
- More pampers.
- Yeah, is that what y'all were doing?
You were like, "It's gotta
be a boy at some point."
- Yeah. You know, after
you, after you a man
and you have six daughters, you like, wow.
And now I'm 51. So I-
- A lot of estrogen.
- It is. And I, and my son
is gonna be walking around
with 80 year old dad at the game.
(chuckling)
- No.
So, you know, my son forced
me to take care of better,
better care of my health now. Cause-
- Is that's a trick?
- I gotta be there for all the kids.
- Oh my God. That's a
lot though. Six girls.
That's amazing.
So you took your youngest daughter.
Was it Disney on ice? Is that what you-
- Took her to Disney on ice?
- Was that fun?
- I had more fun than her. I think-
(laughing)
cause I've never been
- I I'd never been either.
My kids have been and they
loved it, but I just love how
in awe she is the whole time.
She's just sitting there
loving it the whole time.
- I enjoy Disney on ice. I mean, you know
you get a chance to watch
the kids enjoy they self.
And, and like I said, it's
a good show for an adult.
If you ain't never been.
- I've never. Yeah. I've never
- You know, the ice skating
and the Moana comes out,
they got the lights.
- And have you ever ice skated?
I'm like just staying
up. It's hard for me.
Just like not falling. I'm
always really impressed
by people moving around on a little blade.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's hard. It's hard
- I know. I got a lot of junk
in the trunk item off weight.
I'm off filter. I'm like,
it's not gonna work out.
So let's talk about the
special. It's hilarious.
I love that. You were
like, play that again.
- I appreciate it.
- So it was filmed in Indianapolis.
So what's it like to perform at home?
Do you love that? Or do you get nervous?
- It was tough performing and you know
I decided to do it because
I wanted to, you know
every time I come back home, they like,
"Man when you gonna do something for us?"
Cause I'm always doing
specials in another city.
So I said, you know what, I'm
gonna do one in my hometown.
And I was so excited and happy.
And man, when I walked out on that stage
and I seen all my childhood
friends, I seen my lawyers.
(laughing audience)
Cops that chased me before, you know.
- When you see your
lawyer, are you worried
about what you're gonna say?
Like, and Laura's like, don't say
- That I gave him a
shout out in on the show.
I gave his name as Jeff Ball.
When I gave him a shout out.
I said, "Everybody give
it up for Jeff Ball."
He saved me from doing 20 years
and he stood up. Going crazy.
- He's like, you're welcome.
- And he called me, he
called me the next day,
called me the next day.
He said, "Oh man, my phone
is ringing off the hook.
Everybody want me to represent 'em now."
(clapping and laughing)
- You say something like
that. That's amazing.
Yeah. So wait, we both grew
up during the eighties.
So what were your favorite
parts of the decade?
Did you love the music
- Man? I love the music, man.
We used to have a, a, a show
that came on Friday night
in Indiana called Night Trax.
And they played all eight-
- With an X?
- a Night Trax
- Trax with an X.
- Yeah, with an x.
- Maybe they were cool.
- Yeah. Yeah. And they played, man.
They played Bruce Springsteen.
They played, played-
What's her name?
Grace Jones.
- Yeah.
I got introduced to a lot of
music from the eighties that,
you know, it's like, yeah.
Eighties music was the best.
- I feel like too, like
radio was more broad.
Like you could hear
like so many different kinds
of artists on one station.
- Yeah!
- Yeah. I like
- That. British music.
- I love what-
- That's why people like, you know,
a lot of my black friends they like,
"man, how you know all this white music?"
- Night trax
- Night tracks with an "x".
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They knew what was up
- (singing) Is a rhinestone cowboy
- Cowboy. Yeah, exactly.
- I was livin' on a- see
I ain't know I know that.
- I know, but you that and
Grace Jones and Bruce frees
they're all on the same
chant- that's amazing.
- And I know Pushinsky you
ever heard of Pushinsky-
- No, Pushinsky-
(laughing)
That Sounds like something else
- It's a rapper. It's a (laughing)
- Sounds like something else.
Maybe it's a different
name where you grow up.
I don't know. It's a family
show. Sorry. I took it there.
So, so before we go, what
advice would you give me?
I'm entering my forties. I'm excited.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
Cause I feel like when
I turned 30, I was like
I have a little figured out.
This is so great. I'm getting older.
And at 40, I feel like
I'm like, it's awesome.
Cause I know I don't have it figured out
and that's like fine.
It's like Yeah. Cool.
- Well, you know what
you, you about to be 40.
That mean you are seasoned.
- Yes. Experienced.
- Experienced.
- I like to, wise.
- Right. But you still a kid too.
You still-
- I'm a child at heart.
- Still got, yeah. You
still got a childhood.
So that's a great age.
You know? I think 40 is.
- I feel like it's gonna be good.
- It is.
- Yeah.
And then at 51,
- Yeah?
- You, you think you
running faster in your mind
but your body ain't running fast.
- Dude.
- I was doing that the other day.
- It's different.
- I was running,
but my mind was running
faster than my body.
- Everyone. Yeah. Everyone
keeps telling me about that.
And it's like my eyesight,
that's the thing.
Like I had LASIK surgery
down when I was like 20.
And so I've like 20, 20
but I've noticed literally just now.
It's like what?
Like I can't my eyes, the vision
and thing is happening
and that's not cool.
- That's right.
- I think I'm a look sexy
in some readers though.
Yeah. I'm gon' make readers look real hot.
- Hey Kelly, you gonna look good.
Anyway it go.
- I'm gonna make some
sexy librarian readers.
It's gonna be so good.
- How you gonna do your eyeliner baby-
- I'm, I'm gonna turn all the men on
at the Jeartok convention.
It's gonna be so good.
- Jeartok.
- Yes, its gonna be good.
All right.
Thank you so much. Mike we love you.
- I appreciate it man.
- Oh my God, your scenes
have been so funny.
- Mike, will be part of,
Netflix Is A Joke: The
Festival, on May 5th
so go online right now for tickets.
Y'all gotta check that out.
Also be sure to watch his comedy special.
It's called "Mike Epps Indiana Mike."
Mike and it's streaming
on Netflix as well.